[Applause]
up ahead quickly don't get back the
grave duck said in front of DeLorean Wow
was that impressive
standing still and though post up here
he comes
[Applause]
took off the fifth year senior and that
explosive boob rim Jim that wasn't a
first step that was a first blur right
there just when the groins it got bumped
a little bit as well I think it wets two
big plays there bacon
McQuaid loves the shot on the wing fakes
it though
[Applause]
Paul Westphal that is unbelievable
hor as Ian you're out
that's no one where you are for Texas
though the twos for Williamson look at
it efficiently thoughts on
and as he should look at this little
deaf Mouse man said bring it at all
fourth foul on DeLaurier whoa we got a Z
and now we got an X said that in he said
it best oh what a pass there dude once
he gives it up face bar hey don't over
help
what a play called my top ism in that
timeout rendition parrot now are the key
guys I think is back to the forum to put
it in play it's it's a parrot
he's in the pain he slashes he shoots
and he'll shoot a couple I actually
thought the bigs there for Michigan
State did a pretty good job of walling
him up he's about a 66 percent
free-throw shooter little contact there
yeah that little left hand I think got
in there
Tillman by the way collects foul number
four you got to be alert now to shot on
the second one
you got a squeeze Williamson if you're
Michigan State and watch for his foot
speed to first let me know now you got
to think five seconds gotta learn five
attempt it I've attempted what do you
think the miss this woman like that this
is almost the exact last night near
Virginia down yeah that game just past
it yep Michigan State you got to pick it
at UCF game block out second when he
tries to miss it but it drops that to
the high bounce gonna give us and they
had a foul to give so that's all
[Applause]